my name is my name is Bob and this is my
wife Tammy and we live here in Hudson
Ohio we met one to two years ago we
started dating after high school after
you had gone up to about money
this isn't about dating by the time that
we got married we were $20,000 in debt
after a bob got out of the Navy we moved
back to California and had our son Tyler
who's a junior
yeah we had a nice big house and the
suburban that was brand-new and two kids
and white picket fence we thought we
were really living the American dream we
moved up into three different houses and
probably a three year period you know we
were 24 years old we don't know anything
really you know and we were like playing
house we're playing grown-up well it was
right in the height of the housing
bubble so it created this death snowball
so to speak this is the opposite of the
good snowball so how much have you paid
off
four hundred and fifty six thousand six
hundred seven dollars and ninety two
cents
Wow does that include your home it does
not hey now we have told the house in
California I had all this money from
that and we just blew through it like
there's no tomorrow and what we couldn't
live in old condo Pepito he had new
houses so we bought a new one
we had a remodeling oh we did it's it is
very important to repot it can have
travertine floors in our attic
yeah exactly
well everybody around us they were
calling it jingle mail we're sending our
jingle mail in this week it meant you
mailed the keys back to the mortgage
company just walked away from the house
everybody in our neighborhood was
walking with my houses and we said we
got ourselves into this mess we have to
get ourselves out that first week in
January our church announced that they
were going to be doing financial piece
and we had never heard a Financial Peace
University before we had never heard of
Dave Ramsey before them I mean along the
way we acted like we were normal people
we went out to dinner all the time you
know we did we were out to the movies we
took vacations well we thought normal
people right and I think that that was
another thing that really touched base
with me when we first looked in the
financial piece was that they would talk
about how we expected to be where our
parents were at age 22 it just it it
made it hard because then when we were
on our own it was hard for us to keep
going in that day and we thought we had
to but this time we had I guess what
he'd say a realization that something
needed to change as part of that as
change in our lives we went through
financial peace and third our debt
snowball we did not even know how bad it
was going to be or how bad we had made
it and it's kind of funny because you
know he says now you're going to go home
you're going to fight right in the DVD
you're going to we doesn't home I think
we just cried because of those Lauren
I'm sorry too this was horrible yeah
doing the one of the first steps is to
figure out your your net worth in
network and that was when we really
figured out how that I guess was the
turning it was negative by six figures
and we went no what have we done what
really really struck us was that that
exercise you have to do where you figure
out your debt snowball and you can
actually see how long it's going to take
you to pay it off how is that going to
work how do we I don't even get the
thousand dollars in our emergency fund
baby step one was going to be impossible
so once we started working the plan and
you know you're tithing and you're
you're doing everything in the right
order and then all the family come to
the end of the month and sure we knew he
had a work dextran sure we knew is all
stuff there was money left over it was
like we could make like a $300 extra
payments that was $50 payment and we
called it low position math we kind of
all of a sudden got like this epiphany
and I don't I don't remember oh so that
it was more or less for the kids I think
they're changing our family tree
once we had a reason we were doing it
the site's kind of subsided it was not
coming from our head anymore was coming
from our heart and you know you'll do
anything for your kids we noticed that
they were looking at money different and
they would make comments like I don't
think that we should buy me that as I
got older it was easier for me to see
the long-term benefits of having a
budget as soon as I got a job I made a
spreadsheet when they started it I was
really young and so I don't really know
much different then client relations
using a budget and going on I'm just
going to keep doing that and I've seen
most of the punishment videos I've seen
most of the ways that they budget how
they handle their money so I'm going to
do that make sure that not go a little
bit I think a little bit for saving make
sure it's all squared away I know
there's other families out there that
are like us you don't have to wait for
the kids to be off the college you don't
have to wait for anything it's you don't
have to wait you can do it
the kids aren't going to be scarred
they're going to learn and they're going
to be part of the process and they are
not going to repeat your mistakes or I'm
not going to crush except rely women
Christ it became more of a relational
lifestyle
ideal instead of just a rigorous program
that's got to check off step four you
know part of the emotional strain and
what I think that people don't realize
when they sign up for this is we need
some encouragement there's going to be
the valley there's hills in the valley
through the entire program and I think
that was part of what got us to the side
to coming in doors as free screen
because you need to take care of money
you got a you got to grab it and you've
got to mold it if I don't do that it
will mold me it'll take over my life
there the whole philosophical path you
can go down as far as whether people let
life happen to them
or whether they make your own path of
mind from we decide to make our own path
definitely what
[Music]
[Music]